Let's add a drop down so
the user can pick when they
want to eat the menu item.
I've added a dropdown with options for
breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
Now we just need a button.
There we go.
We're now set with all HTML content.
But choosing an item still doesn't make
it appear up in the order tracker.
Let's wire the different
parts of our app together.
Ember controls user
interaction through actions.
The default action is a click.
So adding this action to our
button will listen for a click.
It'll call the chooseItem function and
pass along the item's name.
This function is defined in
the menu items component's file
inside an actions object.
Let's set up the action and
action handlers.
Clicking the button now calls this
function with the items name.
We need to create this function
in the Component File.
All actions need to be
inside an actions object.
Note that this is actions with an s
while this is action without an s.
the function is called choose item and
it receives the menu name.
When the button is clicked.
The order manager service needs to
be updated with the new selection.
We don't have access to the order
manager in this component yet.
So we just need to inject it.
Now have access to the order
manager service under this name
to update the service when the bun is
clicked, we first get the service and
tell which meal to add the item to.
Remember that this method already exists
on the order manager service object.
I've hardcoded the default
meal time to breakfast but
users really should be
able to choose the meal.
I switch things around to use this
property which still defaults to
breakfast but
with this set up we can use
the template to update this property.
This adds an action to the select
element that fires on change instead of
one being clicked.
It calls the change
category function and
passes along the value
that was selected.
The change category function
just updates this field.
Now we can choose a menu item and
have it show up in the order tracker.
How awesome is that?
Now we just need a way to let
the user cancel one item and
change the active day.
We'll add both of these to
the order tracker component.
So if a menu item has been picked for
a meal,
we want to let our users cancel it.
This will check if a menu
item has been picked.
This is just an x symbol that,
when clicked,
will remove this day's breakfast item.
Let's create this action
handler in the component file.
This remove function tells
the order manager service
to remove the menu option for
the meal time of the past and day.
To let users choose the day
they're adding meals for,
we'll add an action to this div.
Remember that we're looping
over each day of the week.
So this day will change with each loop.
Clicking this div will call this
action passing along this day.
The set day to function just tells the
service to update the selected day and
we're finished.
Our app displays content handles user
interaction and manages data and
it does all of this instantaneously and
with no patriot precious.